good afternoon my name is David Cameron
I'm the director of the program on
in studies at the Macmillan Center of
Yale and it's my pleasure to moderate a
conversation this afternoon with a
number of people who are affiliated with
the Macmillan Center and with Yale we
are focused on the impact on democracy
of the kovat 19 pandemic and in
particular the question of whether this
is in some way creating a basis for a
move to authoritarianism in some states
either greater authoritarianism than now
exists or democratic states that are
moving under the pressures of the
pandemic toward something less than full
democracy we're delighted to have a
number of experts on various parts of
the world today and I want to introduce
them to you and then we'll proceed with
a discussion in which each of them will
speak for a few minutes on the topic and
then we'll have a conversation back and
forth among the panel members it's a
pleasure for me first to introduce
Anadolu who is a colleague of mine in
the Department of Political Science here
at Yale Anna has worked on political
economy in Latin America has written a
number of works including crafting
policies to end poverty in Latin America
and she's well versed to be able to
speak both about democratic politics and
less than full democratic politics in
Latin America
Tice Gasparian is an associate research
scholar at Yale at the Yale Law School
she's a lawyer and practices civil law
in Brazil she has served in the past as
the chief of staff and the ministry of
justice in Brazil and she's involved in
a number of commissions dealing with
legal issues in Brazil so she's someone
who is very knowledgeable about the law
and civil law and challenges that might
be created to civil law under the
pressures of the pandemic vish this
octavo is a postdoctoral associate with
the Council on Middle East Studies in
the Macmillan Center she's an expert an
authority on political Islam contentious
politics and authoritarianism in in
particular in North Africa and she is
currently writing a book about Islam in
modern Algeria and she's also written
extensively in various media the
Washington Post national interest
foreign affairs and other publications
need some boost Sam deuced is a member
of the anthropology department at Yale
and a postdoctoral associate in the
program in Iranian studies as part of
the Council on mil the Middle East
Studies in the Macmillan Center here at
Yale and she's also a lecturer in the
Department of Near Eastern languages and
civilizations she works on the
intersection
between politics and and culture she
published a book entitled soundtrack of
the revolution the politics of music in
Iran so we have with night someone who
is knowledgeable obviously deeply
knowledgeable about about that complex
polity Anika sook Suk's is a
postdoctoral associate in Macmillan also
and a lecturer on Russian East European
and Eurasian studies she is now working
on a manuscript entitled contagious
files the cultural memory of state
surveillance in Hungary and is someone
who will be able to fill us in a bit on
what mr. Orban just did in regard to his
decree powers tae-soo zhang is a
professor of law at the yale law school
and is a specialist on chinese law and
Chinese politics he's written about
kinship and property in pre-industrial
of China and England and he's now
writing a book on the ideological
foundations of the fiscal state in China
he's a global faculty member of Peking
University Law School and also the
current president of the International
Society for Chinese law in history so we
we have a wonderful group of panel
members and cover the world quite
broadly and so I think we'll we'll start
and if you don't mind
leading off on a-- with some comments
and then we'll
go to toys and go on from there right
thank you David and thank you to the
Macmillan Center for organizing this
webinar and good afternoon everyone so I
will focus for the most part on Mexico
and Central America but I would like to
start by giving a quick overview of how
things are looking right now in Latin
America as a whole so as you may know
the region is facing a very tough
situation as of yesterday there are 120
2,500 confirmed cases 10,500 of those
cases are in Mexico and about 7,000 of
those cases are in Central America
Brazil has been hit the hardest in terms
of number of cases with 47,000 but if we
consider the number of cases per million
inhabitants the country that has been
hit the hardest is Panama followed by
Ecuador Peru Chile and the Dominican
Republic and on these numbers however as
in many other regions testing has been
limited so the total cases are likely
many times higher than the confirmed
cases and there are two reasons why I'm
afraid that excess mortality will be
very high in some places in the region
and to start with a perhaps no surprise
health care systems are not prepared in
the region to tell which is endemic and
they are about to get a very difficult
stress test Latin America is one of the
most unequal regions in the world and
for many people staying home for an
extended period really doesn't seem
possible because that would threaten
their livelihood and it's very hard to
estimate exactly the number of people
who are vulnerable to this but just to
give you a sense a 154 million people
are 56 percent of workers in the region
operate in the informal sector which
means that they do not have job security
and to make matter
worse for many people frequent
hand-washing is challenging so my
concern is that it's gonna be very hard
to flatten the curve in some of these
areas now the second reason why I think
this is gonna be difficult it's because
in Latin American I'm gonna focus
particularly in the challenge
challenging context in Mexico migrants
and refugees are a very vulnerable
population they lack access to health
care and social distancing is basically
impossible especially for those people
who are stranded in the camps in the
southern US a Mexico border so the New
York Times says I think this could
really become a humanitarian disaster
now some governments have responded
early to the pandemic some have dragged
their feet and some like in Nicaragua
have not even responded yet notoriously
presidents in Mexico and Brazil dumped
made the threat and times will speak
about the case of Brazil but in Mexico
Lopez Obrador
or my administration delayed most of the
quarantine measures that other Latin
American countries have already
implemented and on the other extreme we
have in asteroid or buchelli
quarantine the country even before it
had from rare cases and the responsive
government has also buried in terms of
its stringency in Mexico the government
is urging people to stay home they have
closed schools and in the end of March
the government shut down all
non-essential activities and in Central
America except for Nicaragua all
countries have quarantine have ordered
curfews and closed borders the salvador
has taken the most stringent of the
measures with even some constitutional
rights temporarily restricted as early
as mid March so I think that it's early
to tell exactly what the effects of the
Panama will be on the political systems
of this countries but I in terms of
democratic backsliding I see for red
flags
in Mexico
I think that checks and balances to the
executive power were already weakening
before copied 19 and I see no good
reason for this trend to reverse Lopez
Obrador party controls a majority in the
lower house of Congress and it's very
close to controlling two-thirds of the
Senate in his few years in office he has
appointed four out of eleven Supreme
Court judges he has attacked our turn on
most agencies including the National
Institute for access to information and
the electoral Institute and he recently
rip and his attack on free media and
perhaps a equally worrisome for the for
for the current circumstances he is
dismantling a state capacity and so far
he has refused to change his economic
and social policy plans and considering
both the head and the economic crisis
that are coming I think both will fall
for very shorts and they would
definitely not help him achieve his goal
of ending corruption and putting poor
people first we like to say and just to
give you an example his social policies
target people who are about to enter the
labor market or who are retired and they
do not reach the millions of people that
work but work in the informal sector and
those who work in the formal sector who
will very likely lose their jobs and
likely be livelihoods in the next few
months so I think that we should keep an
eye on what Lopez Obrador makes here and
the decisions he takes once the economy
unravels and perhaps his popularity
starts to fall in particular we should
pay attention to the midterm and local
elections next year yeah the second red
flag now is that Isis in El Salvador and
we ve already sort of perceived this
well given what they the measures that
they have taken some analysts really
worried that buchelli is using covet
19th as an excuse to continue
militarizing the country and as I
mentioned constitutional rights have
been temporarily suspended
it's particularly worrisome the third
breath like I see is the continued
presence of non-state actors with
immense economic power in many of these
countries and it's early to tell what I
think we should keep an eye on how
organized crime and drug cartels would
react to the pandemic in particular I
worry that they will use this crisis as
an opportunity to expand their grip on
communities and use their excess cash
liquidity or wealth liquidity to buy
elections and finally the last red flag
that I want to mention is that many
countries in Latin America so massive
protests with very legitimate demands
before copied 19 and this protest went
from what a man a Nicaraguan gunas
Mexican many other countries in the
Southern Cone I think that a the right
to protest must be fully guaranteed once
the health emergency passes and I think
it's going to be very challenging for
governments to deal with social unrest
and particularly because they will be
cash-strapped so we should really pay
attention on how governments are going
to deal with social arrests hey once
apon demian it allows people to go back
to the streets and so just in some I
don't see covered 19 is unveiling new
autocrats in the region but I do see
that perhaps it's speeding up some of
the backsliding that had already begun
and before got nineteen thank you great
thanks thanks very much
Hana Thais would you like to take the
microphone yes can you hear me it's okay
I'm okay so thank you for inviting me to
be with you today
I'm very honored with this invitation
and thank you David for your
presentation and also for your Latin
America view point of view because it's
much what I'm going to tell you today
it's
you have already pointed out so let's
Sunday our president bosun ro he
participated in demonstrations in
Brasilia our capital will where
protesters called for military
intervention they also shouted against
the Congress and the Supreme Court they
wanted the Supreme Court and the
Congress to be closed and they make
pressure for an end of the social
isolation recommended by the health
authorities that's more or less similar
what's happening in u.s. but the
difference is that the president joined
the crowd he covered in front of groups
of people without wearing a mask
obviously risking not only his own
health but of others and he defended the
violation of democratic order shouting I
am the Constitution it's a known where
the priest the president is an idiot or
whether he is an authority there is an
authoritarian logic behind his speech
since then each one of President Zuma
who said two years ago the country has
been divided by polarized political
opinions on the right that we which Bo
scenario comes from an anti-democratic
and bigoted mentality has been gained
force as if there were not enough on
anti-scientific wave has also reason the
president's mentor says that nothing
disproves the contractor that the earth
is flat that's what we are living here
so unlike many government officials who
would have taken advantage of the
pandemic situation to take severe
measures and gain political support both
soon our opted for denialism he stands
as one of the rare case of a head of
state who despite being authoritarian
does
recognize the seriousness of the crisis
and does not use it for his own end but
the president has been attempting
initiatives that limit liberties and
freedom recently he added provisions in
a bill that exempted the government from
providing information for the population
the bill was not approved thanks to the
mobilization of the society but one
mother's for how long this can last and
because of the coherence speech the
president addressed to people he lost in
popularity and is isolated politically
some voice their opinion that both on
arutz connected messages would serve as
a political armor to prevent the
inevitable economic and social effect of
the pandemic from being used against him
in the race for the elections in two
2032 Oh about the about his popularity
although he remains at 30 percent
approval rates the president's
popularity has dropped a lot since his
election many politicians who supported
him a year ago are now his opponents I
want to to put a nice light here I'm
just going to share my screen I don't
know if it's going to to work but here
you can see both Sinatra's popularity
before and after depend on you
so in the left side my left side you can
see the red trace is horrible stand for
a horrible or very bad popularity and
the truth was I liked blue it stands for
very very good and the dark green stands
for a regular so you can see that after
the Panda Mia the red red trace is very
is much higher and
his approval of very good and regular
has dropped it has been dropped so
that's a graph that I wanted to show you
today there are 35 million Brazilians
without access of two running water
instructions on washing hands and by
hand sanitizers seems completely ironic
and nearly useless the situation on in
the puke poor communities as the favelas
slums offers no conditions for social
distance as Ana has just thought large
families live in houses just one room
without any privacy in 2018 low before
the coronavirus crisis the number of
Brazilians living in other the stream
poverty line reaches 13 million with
people living on less than one dollar a
day it's not difficult to understand
that for a huge number of Brazilians the
President's speech against social
isolation makes more sense than the
recommendation of doctors addressed on
white in white who they see on TV Brazil
is the sixth worst country in the world
in terms of social inequality in such a
diverse country with such different
social conditions the pores will be we
certainly be the population most
affected by the epidemic also not matter
chain tension has been paid to the
situation in the Brazilian prisons which
are completely overcrowd and with with
extremely poor hygiene Brazil has one of
the largest prison population in the
world and when epidemic arrives in
prisons the perverse collection
correlation relation of pandemic and
social network
will be made very very clear does the
situation with the pandemic in Brazil
tends to be more kilometers than
everything than anything ever witnessed
before we are frightened that people
will then agree to exchange their
liberties for security the urgency that
will be necessary to feel to place the
crisis will certainly facilitate the
adoption or future measures of exception
that limit freedoms in elías just to
give you an example in early April the
Minister of Economy stated that
democracy gets in the way we all know
that adoption of democratic routines and
methods is very slow democracy is not
efficient when we are in a hurry this
point of view might explain the common
sense of the population who taken to the
streets asking for military intervention
in short what we see in the country is a
propitious scenario for chaos that will
be shared by a goofball
a madman with a team totally insensitive
to social issues and human rights it's
not yet clear how the president will
benefit from this situation or what
political views he will make from it but
at least at least we have it's clear
that with each verbal assault against
the democratic order the Congress and
the judiciary are strongly positioned in
the defense of constitutional principles
it's true that the authoritarian wave it
is accelerating worldwide some health
policies as such as a confinement or
cell phone tracking may be implemented
and will bring a great deal of intrusion
into people's lives the question is to
what extent people will be willing to
exchange liberties for safe and economic
stability with regard to the presidency
of the Republic Brazil is completely
seems to be completely adrift a few
weeks ago a journalist asked to the vice
president
Antonio am utamu Rome who is who used to
be a general in Brazilian army
if the situation so the journalist asked
him if the situation was under control
in the country to which the general
replied the situation is under control
we just do not know by whom that's
that's the view from Brazil that's the
problem here in Brazil thank you
you have to unmute yes yeah at times at
times I thought you were talking about
this country in terms of the presidency
very very interesting and a nice
comparison also with what honest said
earlier this would you like to tell us
how you see the problem from your
vantage point so thank you ty Santana
first sort of breaking down the South
American and Latin American scenario my
remarks will shift just ever so slightly
to focus on how the Cova 19 crisis is
affecting social movements in public
life under authoritarian regimes and I
focus on the case of North Africa and
for the sake of time and scope I'll
focus on Algeria specifically today but
I'll be happy to sort of compare and
engage the Moroccan situation you know
maybe in the in the Q&A discussion so
obviously it's been sort of widely
commented upon that in times of crisis
you know the coronavirus of today you
know the 911 of yesterday and a
subsequent global war on terror that
regimes especially Arab authoritarian
regimes will sort of instrumentalize
these periods to consolidate power limit
freedoms and control the nature and flow
of information but the Algerian you know
my research in Algeria and the Algerian
scenario broadly sort of shows a bit
more of a complicated picture and so I'm
gonna talk a little bit today very
briefly about Algeria's recent
anti-government protest movement called
karach which though it has sort of
definitely been reshaped by kovin 19 it
has not been ultimately put down or
sidelined by the current health crisis
or by the sort of unhinged authoritarian
repression that many assumed would ensue
and in fact the the Algerian regime is
perhaps a bit more hamstrung than many
similar governments in confronting the
crisis precisely because of sort of
sweeping unilateral top-down
technocratic response would invite the
very accusations of authoritarian power
grabbing that has created the current
crisis of legitimacy to begin with
and so in turn the sort of tentative
response at the Algerian government has
been compelled to take house ironically
fete you know fed their protest
movements narrative of state and
aptitude so just a just a little bit of
background about the movement it was
formed in 2019 in protest against
President of Buda flicka's announcement
that he would run for a fifth term and
in April of last year it brought to an
end his 20 year rule and over the year
Chirac has morphed into sort of this
massive nationwide movement that is sort
of unanimously calling for a complete
overhaul of the Algerian political
system and I would say and I think
others would agree that it's probably
among the most significant unform alized
non-state sort of entities to arise
against the sitting government in modern
you know Algerian memory up until he
rocks formation sort of anti system
sentiment in Algeria had been sort of
kind of hush-hush something that you
sort of say behind closed doors in
private among people that you trust but
the sort of mass support that Iraq has
been able to mobilize over the last year
has sort of exposed these sort of anti
state sentiments as much more widespread
therefore kind of normalizing and sort
of making more legible these very public
expressions of dissent and kind of
outwardly revealing you know people's
actual preferences as well as the
state's sort of utter lack of legitimacy
in public trust and you know over the
course of he rock therefore you know
streets and public squares became these
sort of sites of the renegotiation of
the imagined Algerian future sites of
unity where diverse and even opposing
camps you know religious groups
secularists Islamists sort of came
together to sort of redefine belonging
in the algerian body politic through a
rejection of the status quo arrangements
of power and you know where public space
has sort of been implicitly state
surveilled for decades occupying space
in this way sort of together gave many
citizens a sort of renewed sense of
civic ownership and also this type of
patriotism that could be delinked from
perform
loyalty to the state but now instead
through you know loyalty to the fellow
Alger in which we see now is being
marshaled in how he Iraq is handling the
coronavirus and so one of the major ways
I see coronavirus is kind of changing
the nature of contentious politics and
social movements which of course we know
is a hallmark of you know functioning
Democratic cultures and also an
important check on authoritarian power
is effectively by stripping these
movements of their most fundamental
resource which is you know space
physical space public space and its
occupation is sort of a critical site
and mode of claim making for social
movements everywhere and so to contend
with this new loss of space which in
many ways perhaps symbolically is back
in the hands of authorities because of
the lockdown Iraq is sort of changing
its mobilisation attack --tx to refocus
its grievances on the states management
of the health crisis it's shifting its
mode of anti state contention from
weekly protests which it can no longer
do - instead online activism and new
grievances and demands that sort of call
out the widening gaps in Algeria's
health infrastructure it's governance in
its leadership as well as towards
efforts in forging may be more prominent
larger role in health service provision
and even policy on health um so you know
now Iraq has almost entirely changed its
repertoire of activities it's you know
it's galvanizing aid food and medical
supplies shipments to vulnerable areas
it's launching crowdfunding campaigns to
distribute PPE to those in need and it's
effectively morphing into this sort of
massive charitable Network and it has
also leveraged the medical expertise
within the movements own ranks to form
educational groups in localities all
over the country to sort of create
credible awareness and public messaging
campaigns you know to disinfect public
areas and things like this and framing
these changes in modes of action as
filling the gaps of the state in this
way sort of works to confirm public
distrust on this and also it works also
to sort of more symbolically you know
trespass on the state's mantle as this
sort of benevolent you know
providential figure which is a concept
that a lot of authoritarian regimes rely
on for legitimacy and so this issue of
public trust in turn has sort of
presented a paradox of course to the
regime's management of the crisis not
only because it was unable to more
swiftly elicit popular behavior change
you know like staying home and
maintaining distance but also because it
just made it much more politically
costly to take on the sort of strident
measures that its neighbors like say
Morocco was able to take in the early
stages to curb transmission for instance
the state could only really implement
curfew lock downs and some harder hit
localities mandatory confinement after
the seriousness of the pandemic became
more inescapably clear to the public and
the government still has not been sort
of able to declare a nationwide state of
emergency as neighboring countries have
done and when it did ban gatherings in
early mark
to the protesters or not and so this
very sort of Senate ofnews has in turn
sort of dampened public confidence and
confirmed the narrative of a slow and
unprepared government that the public
needs to fill in for and finally even
though you know president Abdul Majid
aboon who was like elected you know
during the he Rock movement this past
year and has sort of near-zero popular
legitimacy you know he promised a you
know sufficient ICU beds respirators and
test kits a few weeks back he rocks
medical professionals came out warning
that you know soon these are each gonna
you know these are these will soon reach
capacity and insufficient testing and
detection medical supply rationing is
soon gonna pose even more layers of
state corruption and mismanagement on
you know all of which is probably going
to serve as even more fodder for dissent
on the part of the Algerian public and
so to conclude really quickly you know
crises like Cova nineteen can be great
for authoritarian regimes and I'll
juries neighbor Morocco may actually
better you know maybe a better example
of this for the government's response
has been a bit more popular despite
people just trust of the health
infrastructure and has reinforced the
seeming
competency of the technocratic state
that is sort of headed up by the
monarchy and if when we contrast this to
the Algerian scenario what is shown is
that Cova nineteen kind of kind of
helped authoritarian consolidation only
if certain requirements are met and
that's namely the issues I mentioned of
public trust and legitimacy and I'll
stop there my comments okay thanks very
much fish and I think we turn to Naheed
great so I'll I'll be speaking about
Iran though I'm happy to answer
questions about the wider Middle East in
the Q&A section but similarly to fish I
think in order to explain what's been
happening in Iran I need to provide a
context as to where Iran was where the
Iranian state was in terms of State
Society relations leading into the
pandemic and you know as you all know
Iran has been under severe sanctions by
the US and Mike
attention the rest of the sort of
Western world since really 1979 but
these sanctions got a whole lot worse
with the Trump administration with its
maximum pressure campaign which openly
seeks to bring down the Islamic Republic
and so as part of these sanctions in May
2019 the u.s. also put a ban on the sale
of Iranian oil which led to the economy
to contract even further now down sort
of by 15 percent and its currency to
devalue by 70 percent and in November
the government decided to cut fuel
subsidies which led to widespread
national protests that became very
violent and in which the state forces
killed some up to a thousand people the
state actually itself has never
published any numbers as to how many
people were killed in those protests but
people think up to a thousand people
were killed which was unprecedented in
the history of violence visibly protests
in post-revolutionary Iran and so the
population was really in a state of
shock and the state's legitimacy at an
absolute low toward the end of 2019 and
then in early January on January 3rd US
forces in a targeted strike killed
general awsome Soleimani a generally
well-liked general in in Iran even
across political lines and this for a
few days brought together a lot of
different Iranian people have different
political backgrounds and factions and
created a sort of unity that was widely
televised on on state media and really
created a sort of gave the state a
reprieve from what had happened in
November with the protests but this sort
of honeymoon period didn't actually last
long because then a few days later on
January 8th Iran shut down the Ukrainian
airliner leaving Tehran which it
admitted only a few days later killing
all 176 people on board and the fact
that the state took three to four days
to admit to its wrongdoing and admit
that it had shut down the airliner
really created legitimacy of major
legitimacy crisis for the state people
poured into the street into the streets
again there were widespread protests
again and
while this was happening the state you
know was really hunkering down for a
worst sort of turnout for the
parliamentary elections on February 21st
which materialized the low turnout of 42
percent the lowest ever since the 1979
revolution for parliamentary elections
and so it was really against this
backdrop that Corona entered the the
picture in in in Iran the first cases
were confirmed on February 17th in Rome
the holy city of Rome where you know it
has something like 20 million visitors
every year and as a really big Shiite
hub in Iran with people coming both from
the east and the West from Iraq Lebanon
from Afghanistan India and Pakistan and
so it's a real hop for for people in the
region and those first cases that
appeared the government like elsewhere
not unlike in the US and elsewhere was
really downplaying the threat of the
virus and only on a February sort of
about a week or so later the state start
admitting that Corona was appearing in
appearing to be a problem in Iran and
shut down universities and schools but
even so it really dragged its feet on
shutting down shrines and mosques and
even though it was appearing as a
epicenter of the virus in the region
really dragged its feet on shutting down
those religious centers and eventually
by the end of February this happened in
fact considering the strong response to
protesters back in November it was
really surprising how little enforcement
the state was taking in public spaces by
March the messaging from national media
was clear stay home there were banners
and posters all around the country but
it still hadn't implemented any kind of
quarantine or lockdown so people were
advised and recommended to stay home and
to not travel but even ahead of the New
Year celebration which happens on the
21st of March in Iran there were images
of you know packed bazaars in Tehran
people shopping and so on so it wasn't
being enforced on the streets eventually
on a on the cultural level in trying to
really get people to under
and the severity of the of the disease
state television stepped in and was
running programs including a film about
Avicenna
from back in the 11th century
introducing you know narrating the story
of him introducing the method of
quarantine as an Iranian medical
intervention and this really found
resonance with Iranians because they now
you know were claiming that the
quarantine is actually an Iranian
concept and so this was adopted across
not just Iran but also the Persian
speaking region Tajikistan Afghanistan
the film was also broadcast the point is
that the you know the in order sort of
enforcement of the public was really
happening on a cultural level and a sort
of suggestive level but as far as the
streets and public spaces were concerned
Shore universities and schools were shut
down mosques a bit later but it really
took a while for and then you know the
state sent in these trucks with a huge
sprays to disinfect public spaces as a
show of corona being a security threat
and by the end of March
death numbers had already surpassed
3,000 so all this was happening while
Iran was clearly being seen across the
world as an epicenter of the of the
virus but all in all when we look at
Iran as an authoritarian state it didn't
carry out the kinds of measures that we
saw in China or the United Arab Emirates
or even now Turkey indeed coming out of
a really contentious period following
the November protests and then the
downing of the Ukrainian airliner it
appeared the government wanted to take a
soft approach and perhaps avoid any kind
of a confrontation in the streets
it was the hardliners and the
Revolutionary Guard that kept advocating
for stronger measures something that was
in fact and welcomed by the public so
the moderate government was taking a
sort of you know soft approach and not
really enforcing too much meanwhile the
hardliners and the Revolutionary Guard
which had been the which had been the
body that's a that had suppressed that
demonstration them demonstrators in
November and killed up to a thousand
people they were the ones who were now
advocating for stronger measures and
that was actually being welcomed by the
public I'll speak to what that could
you know what that sort of tells us and
a little bit omits would have appeared
to be a power struggle between the
moderate government and the hardliners
and the Revolutionary Guards it was
really Iran's health care system that I
think we must credit for what is a
relatively low death rate at about 5600
today some sources say that those
numbers are not correct and that the
government's downplaying the extent of
the disaster in fact there was a
parliament parliamentary fact-finding
Commission just several days ago that
released a report saying that the number
of those that is about two times the
number of official of the official
number and the number of those infected
about five times the government says
it's about 18,000 people so they're
saying it must be five times that number
considering the death ratio of those
dead and those infected so even if we go
by about 10,000 dead today that is you
know in comparison to other countries
much better endowed with better medical
systems such as France or Italy or or
Spain that's not such a high number and
I think in it has it's been sort of a
narrative that has been percolating to
the top which is you know that Iran's
health care system which was still
slowly built up after 1979 with a vast
network of community health workers and
primary health care centers around the
country system that the w-h-o at one
point described as an incredible
masterpiece has really stepped in to
become the hero of the nation in terms
of blocking the the worst you know the
worst outcomes of this this pandemic in
Iran and since the outbreak the system
has sent out mobile health stations that
I've carried out a case finding and
contact tracing all across Iran and at
about 1.7 hospital beds per 1000 people
Iranian emergency rooms were never at
full capacity the state has spent 16
percent of its budget to take care of
those in greatest need through foods and
loans and and so on but there's great
discontent across Iran because
apparently those those aides are not
being delivered sufficiently and are
trickling down there
slowly and as you might know the u.s. is
not blocking Iran's request to the IMF
for the five billion dollar billion a
dollar loan the first such request since
the 1979 revolution and so I think what
this tells us is that you know it has
been argued that it's not so much regime
type authoritarianism or liberal
democracy but state capacity to deal
with crises that can best indicate the
path of these of the disease in
different countries but even by this
standard if we look at sort of you know
state capacity Iran is a baffling case
the government itself has not been very
proactive it is not imposed strict for
entire or lock down and it's not clear
that an in this and it's divided system
between elected and unelected bodies it
would be able to muster the kind of
state capacity required to deal with the
public health crisis of this magnitude
but I think what has been sort of coming
you know more and more as a story to the
surface is again this underlying health
care system as well as civil society's
engagement early on so early on when
there was a shortage of goods of
facemasks and other kinds of PPE
personal protection equipment people
started making masks in their small
factories or in their homes and
distributing them there were groups of
the women going around and disinfecting
things like ATMs and public phones and
all kinds of you know most touch sort of
public surfaces and and I think another
factor that accounts for the lower death
rate is probably Iran's young population
you know compared to other populations
of a similar size like the countries I
mentioned like Spain Italy and France
and so what we see is that you know
coming out of a real crisis of
legitimacy following the protests in
November and the downing of the
Ukrainian airliner the government kind
of sort of took a backseat approach and
in taking a backseat approach what has
what the society has revealed is that is
it self-sufficiency as sufficiency and
its own activism in really trying to
keep the numbers down and help each
other there are lots and lots of their
stories all around social media of
people helping each other and their
neighbors and making sure that you know
in a
people know who's sick and who's not and
and coming to each other's AIDS and so I
think coming out of the corona crisis
what I see is as an even greater
strengthening of sentiments around
self-sufficiency and the civil society
which had been crushed to a great extent
in the post 2009 securitization of
politics and public space in in Iran I
think I'll end with that
great thank you very much Naheed I think
now we go to Nikko Nikko yes thank you
thank you so much Maggie thank you so
much for this amazing presentation it's
so funny because Alban is definitely not
taking a backseat approach so what we're
gonna see is something very different
can you all hear me because my mic is a
little hidden and also thank you
aja Kristina and Kathleen for organizing
this event and they read we're so
honored that you agreed to husk so in my
talk I will first focus on the political
events that took place in Hungary during
the last month as a response to the copy
of 19 crisis as much as we can draw some
parallels between the Hungarian
government and the other authoritarian
regimes in the Central and Eastern
European region such as the ruling law
and justice play in Poland or the new
Slovenian government led by unity anza I
will argue that Prime Minister Viktor
orbán's focus on his self image and his
performance as a commanding leader is
distinctive from the anti-democratic
measures with which other prime
ministers and presidents have attempted
to utilize the epidemics to grant their
power so I will also focus on hungry and
we can discuss the other countries in
the region later I would be especially
curious to hear what other scholars have
to say but the other countries to take
the most advantage of this short amount
of time I will first provide a brief
summary of Fidesz government's legal
responses to the crisis most importantly
of the authorization law something that
David has already mentioned that has
been widely discussed in the
international media then I will turn to
Orban or bands lesser-known populist
performative actions the ones through
which he makes himself seen as a
paternalistic and seemingly
authoritative of the activity but not a
theater Ian and that sounds it's an
interesting distinction that I want to
think along with you leader who is
dedicated to the protection of his
people under any and all circumstances
this analyzes will be informed by this
interdisciplinary field of performance
study is my research area which allows
me to analyze performances of politics
along
with political performances so let me
first let me briefly guide you through
Prime Minister Viktor orbán's cooked
etad that took place on March 30th 2020
at this time the Hungarian Parliament
passed a law in which it suspended its
own power and authorized Viktor Orban to
rule by decree for an indefinite period
of time and I want to emphasize that
this was what so up outrages that there
is a state of emergency in plenty of
countries which just had plenty of
examples but the fact that it is for an
indefinite period of time that there
that really opens a new door and in
Hungary the emergency powers can be
lifted only with the support of the
two-thirds of the parliament
which is exactly a major date that Orban
Hall so it really is up to advanced
people at this point if this emergency
will ever end it is also important to
clarify that even with almost present
present ruling by decree the Parliament
continues its legislative work now this
is something that I think was confused
very often in the international media
the Parliament is still working and as a
result it is difficult to identify new
laws and rules that were introduced as
governmental decrees and built the the
Fidesz control that says party feeders
control parliament chose the proposed
and passed during the time of the
epidemics again there has been a real
confusion about this both within the
national and in the international media
Altman has issued some seminal decrease
so far according to the board how am ia
constitutional scholar
some of the decrease include
obliterating data protection in Hungary
obliterating the worker protections in
the labor code and permitting the
government to take charge of public
companies just taking call of them and
so these are the decreases our bans
decrease but simultaneously the
Parliament also established in some
bills that for instance and here I quote
the spreading false information or
through facts distorted in a way that
could impede or forth the effectiveness
of defense measures against the
coronavirus is punishable of one to five
years of imprisonment in other words if
you say something that the government
theme says untrue you can be imprisoned
now
the Ministry of Human Resources Nicholas
Cutler declared that hospitals are
required to evacuate 36 thousand beds
and sent on thousands of chronically ill
and post-traumatic patients who are in
need of long-term rehabilitation
violating international visibility and
human rights and there are speculations
as to why this was necessary in a
country that at the moment has a total
of two thousand and three hundred eighty
three three cases which I will clearly
address in the Q&A but the for the sake
of time for now let's just note that
they emptied 36,000 beds in hungry
hospital beds then there was a
legislation builder proposed to cut the
status of about twenty five thousand
state employees working in the cultural
sectors in museums and theaters there
was another bill that proposed to
classify all information about a Chinese
railway investment in the country of
which we know very little about and
another one which ban which would ban
transgender people to legally change
their sex in the birth registry after
transitioning simultaneously they also
try to limit the power of the municipal
governments but there was such a strong
pushback there even from their own
people as at this time municipal
governments have a lot of a lot of
important work to do that they actually
be thrown there at hand as Anna
Applebaum points out in her outfit for
the Atlantic these issues most of these
issues at least don't have the remotest
relevance to the pandemic and I did such
an important point they are so
imminently if you think about tension
transgender rights Chinese railways
these are the kind of laws that have
been proposed instead I want to propose
that it allows Albarn to cynically
transform his illiberal democracy a term
he has proudly owned
after his 2010 victory into a
dictatorial regime the legal explanation
that the Parliament provided for the
necessity of these emergency
measurements was - and here I quote the
law itself to guarantee for Hungarian
citizens the safety of life and health
personal safety the safety of assets the
legal certainty as well as the stability
of the national economy so it's all
about our safety that the government is
providing for
supposing the words of the law with all
bands public performances since the
belatedly established state of emergency
allows us to demonstrate how he seizes
this moment to reestablish himself as a
paternalistic authoritative father
figure who protects his people from the
gravest dangers that are lurking to
attack from the outside and irony is
intended here in this way Alma's
performance is Jana logically linked to
the post
Dominus communist dictators of Eastern
Europe disguising the little
disenfranchisement and oppression of
people under the kitchen performances of
excessive power and paternalistic care
and it just decided something
interesting that I think is happening
here is that that historians have have
always connected orbán to these non
phobic and nationalistic militant
Hungarian governor of the 1930s Michael
shorty who was one of the x-ray action
figures who very much wanted to become
allies with Nazi Germany but I do think
that the way he the way album performs
himself in this new role of the of the
of the I won't use the term dictator in
control is very much it follows a
different tradition if we listen
carefully to the words of the law we may
better understand why or bunny still
enjoys the majority of the support of
his country through this description we
may capture not only the legal and the
ideological but also the affective
rejects registered through which almost
solidifies his dictatorial power or ban
since the earliest days of the epidemics
has regularly attended hospitals and
demonstrated that he is in full control
of the epidemic and I would love to show
some fixed pictures so let me let me see
if I can just share my screen with you I
should be able to do so okay so this is
just a graffiti and as you can see he
was there to welcome the Chinese
shipments at the airport to control what
control all the health I commanded
arrives he personally was very much in
control of these transactions and then
he also
sorry let me see then he also went to
each and every hospital starting in
April every day he attended a different
Hospital and he made sure that he he
checked the state of those hospitals and
something that you can see that I think
is quite funny this is him this is him
and then then this is one of his last
visits on April 9 is that even his gear
gear has increasingly reflected on both
the severity of the danger and the
readiness of the Hungarian hospitals to
fight this invisible enemy and of course
here I'm referencing unfortunately it
Trump's language these images on for the
visual narrative of an omnipotent and
omnipresent leader who is personally in
charge of the health and well-being of
his country
it is this performance of the country's
leader that evokes the paternalistic
protection of a communist party general
secretary who regularly over to form
their fatherly control so what you can
see here is that he attended all the
hospitals and simultaneously the images
that starting to circulate were the
hospitals that the first thousands of
patients home and the directors of the
numerous hospitals were forces and
thousands of patients home images of
empty hotel hospitals rooms perfectly
prepared for the virus were introduced
in the national media contrasting the
images of horror and death in Italy
Spain and the United States so these
were the ideal images that that the
national media presents in Hungary and
these images and for the visual
narrative of an omnipotent and
omnipresent present leader who is
personally in charge of the health and
well-being of the country it is this
performance of the country's leader that
evoked the paternalistic protection of a
communist party general and here we have
an example of young Escada in 1981 who
regularly over performed their fatherly
control and embraced their people it is
also here I will argue that all body
parts from the other regional and I
suspect some global leaders since he
moved past his early trivialization of
the virus he has created he has created
I said a new visual narrative for
himself on one which spectacular Rises
his protective actions while the puppet
lawmakers in the background ensure that
his dictatorship will be total in an
undefeatable by the time the epidemic is
over through this short presentation my
intention was to locate the tension
between the between that which is
nationally and internationally is
visible and that which is invisible
while the extensive discussions of the
authorization law successfully drew the
International political and legal
community's attention to the dangers of
the unprecedented unconstitutional act
the actual effects of the law is almost
invisible to the Hungarian people for
now at least for now
simultaneously the excessive performance
of power that manifests itself in the
paternalistic care and control is what
accessible to locals and by entities
populist performance is what may
solidify or bans regime for another
decade or it more even more great thanks
thanks very much Anika and now we turn
to tae-soo who will probably be saying
something about China yes
so unlike the many of the other
countries have been talking about theirs
looking going on in time they could be
described as a transition where China
was full the authoritarian before this
it is fully authoritarian after this the
interesting things that talk about are
all about basically how the underlying
politics of that authoritarianism have
actually acted upon the pandemic so I
think we're almost a little bit over
time so turdy really quick the Chinese
the Chinese response can be relatively
clean these separated into two into two
different traces to the coronavirus the
first probably wouldn't you know I think
how early you think the 20s government
election was aware of the coronavirus I
mean the most reasonable estimates right
now are something like late November or
early December from that point up until
basically like a late January the
government was in pretty much like like
all of the worst have
of the Chinese government were pretty
much on display local bureaucrats
fearful of not meeting their own growth
targets or fearful of basically being
reprimanded for causing unrest basically
try to cover up the entire thing at some
point said this intro cover became aware
about central government also was
collaborating with local governments for
quite some time from the December I
words and kind of like downplaying the
severity of the crisis and this all has
a certain kind of obvious authoritarian
module to it the government is heavily
heavily relied reliant upon performance
based literacy and any kind of a major
social climate leading to economic down
leading to economic problems that are
triggered by this by this epidemic would
be of no serious cost to the state's
political standing so initially the urge
both up and down the bureaucracy was to
downplay to cover up to basically try to
maintain a semblance of peace and
normalcy
I think I'm gonna agree this
dramatically the backfired and legs hit
like this math explosion kisses and
Wuhan that's basically even to this
thing we don't know the folks sense of
how serious deep end the epidemic who
was and from the end of January onwards
the government finally come to own up to
the problem the entire time use
machinery need machinery the Chinese
burocracy went into full motion and from
that point onwards it's fitting
relatively I think it's very easy to be
angry if you're outside of China
basically what's been going on inside
the Chinese bureaucracy but I think I
need that the measurement would have to
acknowledge that from something like
January 30th onwards the Chinese
government has been extremely effective
in managing the overall but directly
managing the the shutdown and then the
open mail process it basically shook the
entire country down which with a rigor
that pretty much cannot be cannot be
copied we're talking anywhere outside of
time on this trend the Chinese the
Chinese government had a capacity for
these kinds of like massive social foot
down measures that can't be replicated
outside of that specific context it
did that basically kill Ralphie disease
within roughly two months in China and
now even now to make regard to how much
you have to trust the actual numbers I
think it's quite clear from what's going
on the reports coming out bubbling up
from the ground level and I'll so like
any remotely plausible observations of
hospital hospitalization levels and
economic activity and so on and so forth
that yeah like the epidemic is under
control internal and the kinase opening
up earlier than virtually any other
major economy and so in all likelihood
the the overall quite comic performance
of the Chinese government in that second
half off Y epidemic has been quite good
I think by any standard whether its own
standards were what about any kind of
nationals the first half was a series of
a series of seriously botched botched
botched measures and definitely speaking
you can't forget the first and you're
talking about the second but the really
interesting talk was like how the
politics of played out in light of that
two-staged response so I think it's
pretty safe to say that it's worth it
this is virtually unimaginable if you
were following the Chinese social media
and said I can make too late January
when everyone was freaking out and there
was this massive uproar of anger and
frustration at the government like at
that point I think it looked like me and
virtually anyone else who has been
watching Chinese politics over the past
decade I think we were justified in
saying this was the Chinese government's
most serious threat she was good in the
sea and at least the past twenty twenty
years likely longer than that's right if
there was genuine the genuine
uncontrollable social anger and
frustration that was being voiced in
Lantana
now the if you have any memory of that
what's currently going on as far as I
know things fell on the Chinese internet
or a monster society is working and
think about this entire epidemic has
become a massive
domestic public relations win for the
government and it's been when basically
across the dimensions first yes like
they managed
getting under control too quickly with
relatively few deaths far fewer deaths
than you could have imagined have you
been following this thing in January and
yes the economy's opened up again so
that eases a lot of pressure Plus but
the most important thing as China now
has the virtue of comparisons with major
foreign competitors especially with the
US which I think by any measure has
bashed it's it's pandemic response at
least as badly as China even if you take
China's first step into consideration
and I think by the entire but by the
time this entire thing is over we'll
likely have this perform worsen across
virtually any time imagine as compared
to the Chinese response so that kind of
schadenfreude
matched with genuine genuine
nationalistic pride has given thi fans a
public-relations win and I think no he's
he's really popular with the toilet
operation right now so the question then
is what are the lessons that that the
Chinese government the Chinese
population the government's going to
come out of this learning so here you
know you might hear there's a pretty
strong likelihood that they're actually
learning the wrong lessons right so if
you're looking back at the two-stage
response by the Chinese government it's
quite obvious the first both the success
in the second half and the massive
failures of the first half stem from
basically the same set of institutional
reasons which was that ever since he
entered the power in 2012 she has been
engaging than this like massive
centralization program across the
Chinese bureaucracy
you know the tiger agra sea meets
foreign commentators have a tendency
talk about the finest burocracy overly
sexualized from Mao to now but in
reality the Chinese the Chinese
government went through this massive
piece of transition phase in the in the
80s that would kind of put all the way
to tell pretty much like seven eight
years ago and that was responsible for
lots of the trendy economic growth in
Lee but at the vibrancy in China during
that phase she has had the opposite
instincts he knows he's inheriting a
declining economy is a continent slowing
down obviously and given that you know
he can't rely on the economy to generate
as much as much support popularity and
the generously for him as his
predecessors could
and those things have been basically to
ramp up control and part of that has
been like regaining control of local
governments and robbed massively
centralizing the Chinese progress the
end result of that basically has been to
create all kinds of mismatches of
incentives and principal-agent problems
that weren't nearly as severe in pass
through that kids so that has a lot to
do with the delayed response and your
phases with local government when the
local with local bureaucrats on the
ground and Wuhan only had lots of
institutional incentives to try to cover
up things even be severe Pomerance so
many of the problems stem from a
centralization that said the
effectiveness of the second half also
stems from the fact that China heavily
now has a pretty royal top-down
centralized bureaucracy that can act as
a whole that's pretty much like a
moment's notice if there's enough
political will come down from the top so
I think what's going to happen given
that right now so for sentiment internet
is so favorite game climbs to to the
state and its overall of the epidemic
what's likely gonna happen basically is
the government's going to learn the
wrong lesson that basic you think that
it's gonna over it's gonna over
emphasize the second half asking the
first half it has obvious película to do
that as well and then lesson the lesson
I think that's going to come out of all
this is that our centralized tightly
control burocracy is responsible for our
quote unquote successful management of
the epidemic and of course that's gonna
exacerbate the further the problems that
left at the first half and major major
really have severe economic consequences
stream because it's gonna quite
seriously deflate economic vibrancy
Impala nama Cajun C Impala some
policymaking initiatives I'm going on at
the local provincial level we're frankly
most of the economic action actually is
taking place so if the script the
Chinese government comes out of this
entire thing burning less than it has
today
like the centralization actually work
this time therefore we have two cents
more I think over the long term like the
next 5 10 15 years it's likely gonna
suffer some quite serious economic
consequences as a result of learning the
wrong lesson but I think
the current moment that's what less
likely what's going to happen in terms
of like the authoritarianism I get my
China was focal if I retired before this
is so to the person anything was pretty
much I didn't hear the most serious
crackdown of civil rights in post mal
PRC history that's obviously gonna
continue you know Victor there still are
large pockets of anger amongst liberal
intellectuals who remember the first
time fine we'll just say that once this
entire thing is over the party is not
going to let up on its crackdown that's
a person of these voices are plus again
the the party has come out of this
entire thing playing on the nationalism
of the Chinese population and gaining
quite a bit of popularity it's really
gonna think whatever we did this time
kind of worked and once a things like
that it's going to thank both of the
centralization the control and the
oppression and suppression so it's well
maybe that that's all gonna seem like it
kind of worked it to the partners
benefit in the yet so yeah China's gonna
get more authoritarian but it's gonna
get more authoritarian in this like
nationalism driven centralized fashion
watch in some ways this is quite fun
because it's gonna not only going to
sack the country have quite a bit of a
kind of economic energy but that
combination of centralization plus
nationalism is very off for the path
that leads authoritarian societies down
the path towards focal hotel terrorism
or perhaps immersion baptism I still
think that's able to be unlike the
outcome before the tiniest of them at
this point the trend obviously is quite
worrying at least in those dimensions so
I'm gonna stop there and I'm happy as
everyone else is I think go into the
queue neighs okay thanks very much
ty sue you raise a very interesting
question for for all of us it sounds to
to simplify greatly your analysis the
authoritarianism of China caused it to
delay obfuscate deny hide the crisis at
the outset on the other hand once it was
finally recognized
the authoritarianism of the system
enabled China to to essentially
eradicate the virus as far as we know if
we believe that they de and so forth and
and it raises sort of a pessimistic
message for all the rest of us in a
sense it 'm it implies that the best way
to deal with this is authoritarian an
authoritarian state that can do the
things that china did once it accepted
the fact that the virus existed in Wuhan
and and so it raises it seems to me for
for others the question of whether
whether a democratic polity can respond
effectively is it is it democracy that
makes it difficult to respond are some
democracies more able than others to
respond or is it does it have more to do
with the you might say not so much the
democracy or non democracy of the regime
but the the authority and expertise of
the of the bureaucracy and those who are
actually managing the crisis really
really briefly yeah I don't think the
efficiency has much to do with the
authoritarian nature South Korea was
every bit just just as effective as
China was in this crisis Germany has
been highly effective and plenty of
other countries have been relatively
effective as well the the main thing
that seems to determine how effective
you are is basically how centralized
your resource marshalling is how capable
you are look like the slice of top-down
centralized action because the this kind
of crisis is not the kind of payment
with effectively and it decentralized
way so basically like the the more
efficient the more in control the
central government is in virtually any
state system the more likely you're
going to be able to effectively deal
with this kind of thing China done with
it through flexing authoritarian muscle
one basically shutting the entire
economy down you can also do it like
Germany or South Korea dislike have
massive central essentially driven
testing and you're gonna reach north of
the same results the problem with the US
response obviously husband.you complete
lack if I don't leadership Mississippi
was everything's mean let's say some of
the states are actually quite competent
but that can't solve the national
problem good response in California or
Washington or even as we're seeing now I
wrote to the company response in the
Northeast in the face of this explosion
it's not gonna save the entire country
basically from from basically having
this massive spread so China's main
universe in that case was the
centralization not necessarily
authoritarianism yeah it's an
interesting it's an interesting question
because as you pointed out Germany has
done well on the other hand it's a
federal system the u.s. obviously hasn't
it's a federal system so then the
question is its it may not be central
centralized versus decentralized or
federal versus unitary but yeah yeah
those formalistic different specific how
centrally coordinated this particular
response was Germany has a federally is
a federal system with a very coordinated
centralized policies fine so what
everyone was was acting pretty much as a
whole the u.s. everyone was at the tunki
themselves in the center was
non-existent but that's the difference
not the formal federal structure of the
government's visit right so is this more
question of the might say the bureaucrat
a the the centralization of and the
authority of those in a federal
government who have responsibility for
this domain of policy yeah I would say
that the yeah the critical thing is just
a holistic mark to enough resources and
you could do that as long as everyone's
out
right but of course it perhaps is kind
of easier and I'm like a more top-down
centralizes look like you have in China
result for me but certainly you can have
coordination now he died I'd like to ask
you about following up on your point
about the health system in in Iran and
and the fact that it was seen as very
effective very capable and I think you I
think you said it's now become the
national hero in terms of dealing with
the crisis how do you how just from
taking from that case how do you how do
you fit that into the kind of analysis
that tae-soo has presented in terms of
and the question is it is the unitary
federal is that the distinction is it
something about the bureaucracy and the
organization is it something to do with
the respect for health professionals
some countries have as we know from this
country some countries have more of that
collective respect of where the health
professionals than others how would you
how would you react to that Yeah right
right so anti Sue's point about
authoritarianism I agree because you
know Iran has been has the Iranian
government has been willing to wield its
authoritarian means when it's when it
comes down to political matters of you
know state survival such as enduring
protests and so on and we've seen that
but when it came down to the coronavirus
actually it hasn't really dealt in
authoritarian means in terms of the
kinds of measures that China for example
took or other countries have taken and
so it really was this underlying
existing structure of the health care
system which in Iran there's I imagine
you know across the world that is true
but in Iran in particular I can tell you
there's a lot of is a there's great
respect for the medical profession and
also this historical
identity with you know Abby said not
having been one of the first sort of you
know modern doctor inventor of modern
medicine and so their historical roots
as well that allows Iranian to Iranians
to sort of identify themselves as a sort
of seed of modern medicine and Iran has
a very high output of medical research I
think its 16th or so in the world in
terms of medical research and it has a
very high ratio of doctors to people
high ratio of hospital beds and so there
is that respect but also with the
revolution what happened even though the
medical system was great before the
revolution but the population was half
its size now actually less than half its
size now but with the Revolution the
idea of the revolution was that the
downtrodden though the poor would be
would be served by the new government
and this is something that was
implemented through a social welfare
system including a efficient healthcare
system that has stationed mobile
stations and local units all the way
deep into rural and provincial areas and
so I think you know the health care
system was able to step in but I think
you know it would be wrong to obviously
this is a it is a federal system and the
health minister but the Health Ministry
associated with the current moderate
government of President rouhani and the
government at large have been really
criticised for their lack of action on
taking measures and providing the kinds
of equipment that the health care
workers have needed and it's what we've
seen is more of a because these existing
structures and them bottom-up support by
people ordinary people in many cases of
providing and you know making things in
their homes and supplying these places
but also also a self-sufficiency that
has existed because of the sanctions so
because of these harsh US sanctions for
decades
Iran creates produces 98 percent of its
own medication although it's still
reliant on imports for for content that
goes into that medication so the
sanctions are still having a horrible
impact even in the medical field but
it's it's self-sufficient in terms of
the medical field it's become
self-sufficient and producing medical
equipment medicines and
and you know and because I think that
the sanctions are an important factor to
consider in everything that's happened
with the kernel virus including in its
relation with China for example when
most countries shut down their flights
China Iran did so formerly as well but
one of these its main Airlines for
another three weeks had continued to
have flights to China and this happened
after an Iranian minister met with a
Chinese ambassador in Tehran and so
because of the western sections Iran has
relying has been relying more and more
on China and Russia and so they these
new patterns of dependency have also
played an important role on how the
virus has played out in Iran
on and taste I wondered if you could say
something about the this this issue or
the the analysis that Tai Chi su was
talking about in terms of the structure
of the government and how that has
affected either hindered or enhanced the
effectiveness of the response I mean it
does does federalism we know that
federalism is variable Germany did well
the u.s. hasn't done well how do you how
do you and then of course the question
that tae-soo raised that maybe it's not
that issue so much is just the
centralization of authority and then we
get into the question of the the
professional healthcare and the and its
ability to essentially drive the
response as opposed to being
subordinated to political leaders could
you say something about all of those
issues in the countries you know and and
of course you knows you know several
countries many countries so Hana would
would you have something to say about
that
sure yes definitely a very interesting
it's a very interesting question I think
that to start with I don't see in Latin
America relationship a clear
relationship between political regimes
and how they are responding to the
crisis so there are authoritarian
regimes in the region that are doing
very badly like let's take about
Venezuela so and and they are
democracies that are doing very badly
too so think about for instance Ecuador
and so so I don't see a relationship now
in terms of the federalism and its
structure I think for instance in the
Mexican case Mexico is a federal system
the government started with a more lacks
attitude to the crisis than what
as governors wanted so sub-national
governments have been demanding more
stringent policies more testing more
equipment a more aggressive response to
the economic crisis too so in that sense
I think that maybe the centralization
will at some point help Mexico are
supposed to be a drawback but the
problem is of course that partisanship
gets in the way so one of the problems
is that I see is that coordination
between the central government and
governor's is very much moderated by the
partisanship of Governors and that of
course might become a huge problem both
in terms of how resources are
distributed to deal with the health
crisis and then of course what will
happen afterwards with the economic
crisis and other countries in the
Southern Cone have also federal systems
but slightly more centralized than the
Mexican one overall they all seem to be
doing relatively okay in the response to
crisis I'm just thinking here about
Chile and Argentina where it which of
course have seen a serious increase in
the number of cases and deaths but but I
don't see reports of their health system
on the verge of collapse like what we
have seen in Ecuador for instance which
is a really tragic story so so in so in
that sense I think that it is true that
a coordination is essential but I don't
think that necessarily full
concentration of power in presidencies
is what will help these countries turn
the page and I think that it is
important to continue to have some
vibrant scenes of national governments
and to a certain degree allowed them to
also do their own experimentation on
both how to deal with the health crisis
and there
economy crisis and just to say most of
the health systems in the region we're
not were not were not as prepared as
when some other panelists have mentioned
certainly the Mexican case health system
was underfunded before covered 19
continues to be underfunded there's lack
of equipment lack of doctors and
certainly lack of logistics in terms of
figuring out how to stretch resources so
so that is a problem what do you think
from your perspective yes our just
completely a bit regarding Brazil
because for us the problem is as I said
the president is denial in a denial move
mode so covet governors the state
governors federal is now he has helped
Brazil because they are acting so
governors they are together they they
have a virtual meeting as we are having
now they have virtual meetings and they
are speaking with themselves and trying
to deal with the the problem and they
are sharing some experience some tests
and they are for example they are
experiencing some tests in this in South
Brazil but he agreed to do so there is a
state called Vikrant so in salt and they
are testing some tests and then they are
going to share with other states but the
the central government is completely
ahead not ahead but a part of all that
and so there is no coordination
governors are coordinating themselves
and so and as I just said we are we have
a lack of everything equipment and
logistic and everything but they are try
governor's are trying to help themselves
that that sounds sounds very American
about the governor's helping themselves
that sitting here in Connecticut and a
part of the new northeastern caucus of
Governors that exists which actually is
doing something an N ik oh I wondered if
I could ask you something about
something you said in talking about
hungry and in particular asked you you
alluded very briefly to Poland the
Slovenia and and to what extent the do
you think in the countries of Central
and Eastern Europe the Hungarian
response is seen as an effective kind of
response and does it make does it make
more people more inclined to say well
illiberal democracy is not such a bad
thing
look what Viktor orbán's doing I mean I
can easily imagine that there were
people in Warsaw in the law and justice
leadership who who think that what he's
done is exactly right but I wonder about
other countries slovenia slovakia so
forth could you say a bit about whether
his response is is a general one or is
it just this is viktor orban and and you
can't generalize about anything
beyond the borders of Hungary so of
course my response is based on mostly
based on primary research and secondary
opinions through my colleagues and well
I do you think that's something that we
can all agree on that he is way more
influential than he should be
hungry is such a tiny country in the
middle of the in the middle of Europe
ending of the EU and yet he definitely
set a path that now multiple leaders
want to follow now as far as a liberal
democracy and whether is this a path to
follow I I do think that unfortunately
the place that he laid on especially
with his extreme right ideologies and
conservative and anti-immigration ideas
it's something that that many countries
around us picked up on I think that's
all there is there is a really
interesting question also in the Q&A
that I might just address because we
have a Polish student hi there who is
asking me about do we think that Poland
is and why or why would I think that
sorry I'm sorry that that Poland is also
anti-authoritarian and and so I put you
know what to answer this question I went
back and I started to think about when
did I start to think that Albans regime
is an anti and auditory and regime
what were those points and if I look
back the past 10 years the way he's been
attacking and seizing the judiciary
system attacking the Free Press taking
full control of the economy through all
your kids all of these all of these are
the different ads that together will
turn or turn has turned his regime into
what I would consider as an
authoritarian regimes now with his most
recent actions I did make the argument
that they are to me this is when he acts
as a dictator for for many reasons and
something that I I've noticed but I
think my colleagues should either
support or correct me in this matter
is that many of the measurements that he
did during five six seven eight years
have have taken place in an accelerated
manner in Poland in Slovenia so so the
gradual transition that that was
happening and I think we're definitely
we've been arriving for a while now that
gradual process has been accelerated
important and so to answer your question
you know maybe I I was not recently I
would not necessarily make the argument
that it is no certain regime Poland at
this moment but we will look at the
measurements that are happening in
relation to the judiciary system in
relation to to freedom rights in
relation to to the refugee question I
think we are we are following the very
same stats that hungry took many at this
point not for her many years ago sadly
okay I'm
that we we are going to have to close
our discussion very shortly but before
we do I'd like to ask
vish if you'd like to get into this
conversation and and and in particular
how you look comparatively speaking that
is it at both Algeria and and Morocco
and and in looking at the responses of
those two countries do you think they
look at all too near neighbors to the
north such as France and Spain in terms
of how those countries which have of
course suffered immense and Italy for
that matter suffered immense losses of
life in terms of how to deal with the
problem is there any sense of learning
do you think in terms of how everyone
would like to respond the way China did
but everyone is in China and can't do
that
obviously are there any lessons to be
learned for Algeria Morocco other
countries and and more broadly in Africa
I mean you know the huge uncertainty of
course is where this will go next and
how what effect it will have when when
the virus begins to spread widely and in
Africa yeah so I think one of the the
ironies of you know North Africa as kind
of being understood as always kind of
looking to Europe as a model the irony
of the the kovat scenario is in many
ways Europe has become sort of the anti
model for for North Africa and for
Africa I think in general and for the
Middle East as well I remember there
were a lot of you know jokes and the
onion about how Africa is closing its
borders from Europe from Europeans
coming
in order to keep the virus out and as
you mentioned correctly a lot of people
are looking to China or just the Asian
countries in general as models and their
handling of the crisis and I think both
Morocco and Algeria were sort of
hopefully relying on the fact that they
are in fact authoritarian much in the
way that China is in order to be able to
kind of quickly sort of manage the
crisis and and sort of act quickly and
unilaterally without some of the
handicaps if we can call it that that
sort of federalist systems and
democratic systems are kind of facing in
handling the crisis in a more swift way
so i think some another interesting
thing is if we compare you know Morocco
and and Algeria is there's one of the
questions in the comments asks about
social trust and how important that is
you know as I mentioned in my talk
public trust in Algeria is very very low
in Morocco on the other hand it's very
very high and even though both of these
countries are in many ways similar in
the sense that they're both what many
political scientists would call you know
hybrid authoritarian regimes they use
democratic institutions that don't
really have many in fact prerogatives
you know what is a Republican one as a
monarchy and you know I'm still kind of
in the stages of fleshing out to what
extent the monarchy versus the Republic
model is relevant to to the to the
question of legitimacy in public trust
especially in kovat I think it's still a
little bit tentative and unclear but but
what I can say is that over the course
of the last several years Algeria has
sort of struggled to concentrate
Authority in a single centralized source
and the way that Morocco has you know in
Morocco the foreign policy establishment
its religious institutions and even its
military sort of function in tandem to
uphold the monarchy and the logic of its
of its legitimacy and it's a legitimacy
that is sort of implicitly and
explicitly religious while the more
internally fragmented Algerian state has
struggled at various points to
concentrate Authority in a single source
in fact some of the slogans of the Hurok
movement that I
mentioned in my talk is you know Algeria
has no King and where Republic not a
monarchy
so it's implicitly sort of highlighting
this like non monarchy nests and calling
out the illegitimate sea of the Algeria
state which is quite ironic so I'm not
sure if that answers the question but
there is a question in the in the
audience about that was directed to me
that is a bit related to what I'm asking
about
to your question the impact to the move
online by the he rock movement and this
was posed by Hanna and whether I see
this as creating a collective action or
commitment issue or strengthening the
movement long term I don't know if we
have time for me to answer that question
you know you could I think we do need to
wrap up so maybe briefly and then we'll
just wrap up yeah so just to answer
Highness question on this yeah I think
it's definitely a challenge as I
mentioned in my comments you know the
lack of public space nor the physical
coming together was very very important
in order both to join together groups
that were ideologically diverse to allow
them to sort of convert together on on a
sort of unifying platform but also in a
way that reveals to authoritarian
regimes their strength the comments I
made about revealing what people's
actual preferences were to strengthen
their numbers the Hurok was able to
establish the sort of massive legitimacy
because of its strength in numbers
something that was made very obvious by
its show in the streets by mobilizing
only online it's very difficult to
discern what is the size of the movement
what is the strength of the movement
what is the sway in influence of the
movement so yes the shift to online is
definitely going to be a challenge but
what the heck one of the advantages that
Hurok has is that over the last year it
has start already sort of established
itself as a major major player in
Algerian politics and so the shift to
online as you mentioned the question
about collective action and commitment
issues on you know the free-rider
problem is sort of this endemic problem
to social movements a lot of people who
sort of towards the end
he regret before Kovac started people
were sort of begin you know you know you
know Ramadan was coming up it was cold
in the wintertime a lot of people were
beginning to sort of sit off the
movement and there's this question of
you know well why should I go out in
March and other than these other people
are sort of carrying the mantle for me
and many people are also beginning to
ask whether protests were enough to
elicit meaningful concessions from the
regime so the question are asking is
actually a question that the movement
itself is is sort of wrestling with and
sort of you know it's an open question
so while I cannot really predict the
future I think on the part of many Free
Riders if no not to not to use the term
pejoratively but in speaking to many of
them many there's a sort of a widespread
fear that koban may be sort of the death
knell for Hurok and so many are
wondering whether this will sort of you
know shock the Free Riders out of
complacency and you know lead them to
join back in the streets whenever the
the lockdown lifts I mean it remains to
be seen but I hope that that answers
your question at least for now
Taisha I think I think you wanted to
make a comment and I think this will be
the last word so go ahead go ahead know
that just because there are some
questions from the audience one is from
Hobart Oh castigliano's at what extent
does trust in government and social
trust in general matter to have a more
effective response to the current 19
pandemic or an crisis I think that the
core election is completely the response
that we are going to have from each
government it depends on the the trust
that the populated
people people has in the government so I
think that's completely collection
reluctant sorry great well I want to
thank all of you
for participating in this we've been
going for almost two hours and we could
go much longer but we do have to bring
it to a conclusion so I just want to
thank each of you and of course
especially thank Cristina and Kathleen
who put this together technically and to
thank especially also all of the
audience and all of the people who have
written in and and those of us who've
got questions we'll try to respond to
you if not in this format in another
format but again thank you to each of
you for participating and spending all
this time and bringing so much
enlightenment to this important issue so
thank you and goodbye